[Música]
buenas tardes es un placer para mí el
poder estar aquí hoy con ustedes y hoy
quisiera hablarles acerca de qué es la
brecha de género y más aún por qué
debería de importarte a ti y qué podemos
hacer al respecto
más de 200 años más de dos siglos es lo
que tardaremos en encontrar igualdad
económica hombres y mujeres según el
último informe del foro económico
mundial
y no solo la cuestión económica el mayor
impacto como nos dice el estudio de la
consultora mckinsey sino que la mujer no
solo recibe un menor salario por el
mismo trabajo sino que nos enfrentamos a
diferentes tipos de discriminaciones en
el día a día
en general tenemos un menor acceso
aunque no estar con altos líderes en las
organizaciones
al enfrentarnos a esta situación de ser
únicas
pero de ser la única mujer en el equipo
directivo la única mujer en la escena de
negocios la única mujer en el viaje de
trabajo esto hace que nos enfrentemos a
diferentes tipos comentarios de
discriminación de parte de nuestros
compañeros a veces sutiles otras veces
no tanto
cuando se comete un error en general es
más notorio o al menos nos enfrentamos
al sesgo de que se cuestione si este
error tiene algo que ver con mi
condición de ser mujer es que ya se va a
casar es que va a tener un hijo es que
su hijo este enfermo cuando todos estos
son factores que si nos impactan nos
afectan pero nos afectan como ser humano
no únicamente si eres hombre o mujer
en ocasiones cuando estoy en una reunión
de trabajo y un compañero comete un
error o no tiene algún dato no pasa nada
él tomará las acciones analizará y verá
cómo puede prevenir esto en un futuro
cuando a mí me ha pasado en una junta de
trabajo no tengo un dato o no estoy a
las expectativas a la altura de mis
expectativas que normalmente son más
altas que las de todos los demás o al
menos las de mis jefes no solo me siento
mal por mí sino que me siento mal por
todas y cada una de las mujeres en el
mundo siento que con ese error puedo
estarle cerrando la puerta a otras
mujeres para que ocupen un puesto
similar siento que en ese mismo momento
alguien en la mesa puede estar pensando
es por eso que no debería haber mujeres
en este equipo directivo
y eso eso es un peso grande de llevar es
por eso la importancia de compartirle
hoy este mensaje a todas las jovencitas
y a todos los hombres porque aplica en
general
el ser una mujer una mujer latina ocupa
un puesto de alta dirección de liderazgo
en una empresa global no solo es una
realidad en la actualidad sino también
es una ventaja competitiva las empresas
se están dando cuenta de los beneficios
que se obtienen al abrazar la diversidad
definitivamente hemos iniciado el camino
y cómo vamos en ese recorrido
vemos aquí los resultados de brecha de
género del foro económico mundial vemos
que méxico se encuentra en la posición
50 de 149 países analizados en el mundo
este índice e índice de brecha de género
global mide la diferencia entre hombres
y mujeres en cuatro diferentes
características educación salud
empoderamiento político y participación
económica vemos que la diferencia en
nuestros cuatro índices nos encontramos
con cerca del 40 por ciento de
diferencia a nivel mundial de los cuales
el mayor grave la mayor diferencia se ve
en el empoderamiento político y la
participación económica
porque en educación y salud realmente
estamos muy a la par lo cual es bueno es
bueno saber que hay un gap
hay una diferencia pero al menos no se
debe a que no estamos preparadas sino
que se debe a los roles que la mujer
está dejando de participar a lo que
estamos dejando de hacer
por último en brecha salarial vemos que
hay una diferencia del 20 por ciento es
decir 20 por ciento de diferencia por
hacer el mismo trabajo únicamente
diferente sueldo por el hecho de ser
mujer y en méjico se agrava aún más
llegando a un 34 por ciento
es por eso que quiero compartirles cuál
ha sido mi experiencia que podemos hacer
al respecto yo he trabajado en
diferentes sectores de la industria por
veintitantos años todos y cada uno de
ellos con un ambiente predominantemente
masculino aún recuerdo mi primer trabajo
como todo recién egresado llegué con
toda la actitud con todas las ganas de
hacer lo mejor de superarme de
sobresalir rápidamente y si fui
mejorando me fui ganando la confianza de
mis jefes de mis superiores los cuales
sabían que me podían dar tareas cada vez
más complejas más difíciles y yo
entregaría en tiempo y forma
hasta que se llegó el momento que tuve
la oportunidad de aplicar un puesto
gerencial yo sabía que no iba a ser
sencillo que no iba a ser fácil porque
siendo una empresa con presencia en
diferentes estados de la república no
solo en méxico sino en el extranjero que
todos los puestos de gerentes y
directores en todas las plantas
estuvieran ocupados por hombres
[Música]
no hay que ser estadista para darnos
cuenta de que algo estaba mal
hasta que uno de estos líderes se acercó
a mí y me dijo mira mi hija tú puedes
crecer económicamente en esta empresa te
has ganado la confianza es más te
podemos dar un puesto de estar que
reportes al director pero no te vamos a
dar el título de gerente
es ahí la primera vez que vi claro
que entendí que eso no era para mí que
yo no podía seguir seguir ahí porque yo
quería más
y sabes querer más está bien desear más
está bien tener ambición está bien
crecemos pensando que debemos
acostumbrarnos a lo que tenemos que no
debemos desear más y no es cierto
siempre el cuando el logro de tu
ambición sea resultado de tu bien y del
bien común no tenemos por qué verlo como
algo negativo
pero eso sí el obtener más no será fácil
aquí vemos los últimos estudios que nos
muestran cuál es el porcentaje de
mujeres en los diferentes tipos de
industria aquí vemos claramente los
ejemplos en los que yo he trabajado como
las manufactura y la tecnológica el
porcentaje de mujeres está muy por
debajo del porcentaje de hombres y vemos
como esto se va agravando se va abriendo
la brecha cada vez menos representación
más femenina conforme va avanzando el
puesto de liderazgo
y estos mismos estudios nos dicen que
esto no se debe a que las mujeres no
estemos preparadas o a que no querramos
esos roles que no querramos ser
promovidas o que tengamos mal desempeño
estos mismos estudios nos dicen que en
general se sobreestima la capacidad de
un hombre y se subestima la capacidad de
una mujer la mayoría de las promociones
son hombres se le dan en base a su
potencial a lo que puede llegar a lograr
y a una mujer se le dan en base a sus
resultados a lo que ya logró como ven
esto puede poner complicar las cosas
mucho más para una mujer que va
empezando su carrera y aún no tiene todo
este historial de logros y récords que
avalen su capacidad y su liderazgo
esto aunado a la poca accesibilidad o
probabilidad de conectar con altos
líderes oa la discriminación y
desconfianza que sufrimos en el día a
día
simplemente no ayuda
yo recuerdo en uno de mis anteriores
trabajos donde yo era la única mujer en
el grupo de gerentes todos ingenieros
mis compañeros me comenzaron a llamar
licenciada
y no lo hacían por molestarme de hecho
casi casi era de cariño eran mis amigos
pero debemos aprender a identificar
estas situaciones y educar a nuestros
compañeros a enseñarles que está mal
porque claramente ellos me llamaban
licenciada porque me hacía falta algo
para poderme llamar ingeniero
y ese algo créanme no tenía nada que ver
ni con mi capacidad ni con mi liderazgo
y ese algo ciertamente no tiene nada que
ver con los resultados que damos en las
empresas
así que vemos que vamos mejorando pero
definitivamente nos falta un camino que
recorrer
así es que para sobresalir en este
competido mundo de liderazgo no debemos
dejar lugar a dudas simplemente tienes
que ser el mejor tienes que ser la mejor
en todo lo que hagas todos los días yo
me acostumbrado a tener que demostrar a
muchas personas que tengo lo que se
necesita para estar en la posición que
estoy
que si estoy allí es por mis méritos y
si es cansado pero vale la pena y es por
eso que quiero compartir las
características que mi experiencia me
han ayudado a lograr estar en la
posición que estoy la primera de ellas
es sigue aprendiendo si tú eres de los
jóvenes que piensa que va a acabar la
universidad o la maestría y ya no va a
tener que estudiar estás mal tienes que
buscar diferenciarte tienes que buscar
cómo sobresalir de los demás y siempre
hay algo nuevo que aprender
yo comencé mi carrera en el área de
calidad y ahí fue cuando me di cuenta
que si tenía todas estas diferenciadores
certificaciones títulos me iban a llegar
a lograr más rápido a donde yo quería
llegar y conforme cambiaba de una
industria a otro tipo de industria
siempre había algo nuevo que aprender
pero eso sí se requiere de esfuerzo y de
compromiso porque cada vez que decía así
a un nuevo objetivo tenía que decir no a
muchas cosas teniendo esa limitante que
todos tenemos como es el tiempo tuve que
decir no a tiempo con mi familia a
tiempo de diversión y por supuesto a
horas de sueño pero vale la pena vale la
pena porque eso me ayudó a ser
reconocida como la mejor en mi área
el siguiente consejo que quisiera darte
es vence tus miedos
no tengas miedo de hablar no tengas
miedo de proponer cosas nuevas no te
sientas más pero tampoco te sientas
menos no tengas miedo de intentar algo
nuevo
sabe te capaz de lograr aquello para lo
cual estás determinada
yo en mi carrera por supuesto muchas
veces he tenido miedo desde la primera
vez que tuve que moverme de mi ciudad
natal alejando de mí de mi gran
compañera de vida que es mi mamá o la
primera vez que llevé a mi primer hijo
de 42 días a la guardería no sé si usted
es alguien de ustedes ha experimentado
esa mirada de otros papás cuando
llevamos a nuestros bebés a la guardería
tan pequeños yo sí y muchas veces una
ocasión llevaba a mi nena de 42 días era
su primer día en la guardería
me encontré otra mamá que llevaba su
niña ya más grande en la misma escuela
cuando me vio llegar con mi nena tan
chiquita recuerdo que me vio y me dijo
que bárbara que pequeña como te atreves
pero seguramente no tenías otra opción
ella compadeciendo me y yo pensando
sintiéndome realmente culpable por
dentro y diciendo alejandra en serio no
tienes otra opción
desde que mis niños son muy pequeños he
tenido que estar en constante viajes de
trabajo por muchos días donde no les voy
a mentir muchas veces pensé si realmente
era lo que quería y si realmente no
había otra opción y por supuesto que hay
otras opciones había la opción de
quedarme en casa cuidarlos atenderlos
estar ahí para todo lo que ellos
necesitarán pero yo me di cuenta que yo
no tenía otra opción para realizarme
para lo que yo necesitaba para
realizarme como persona lo cual a final
de cuentas me ha llevado a ser una madre
independiente segura decidida pero sobre
todo una mamá feliz y créanme ese es el
mejor regalo que le he podido dar a mis
hijos
miedo no solo en lo personal también en
lo laboral como cuando comencé a
trabajar en este ambiente global y me
dijeron tu inglés es fluido
yo dije por supuesto y a la semana
siguiente me estaba encargando de
liderar negociaciones con gente de la
india en el otro lado del mundo en donde
el acento no me ayudaba en nada o cuando
dije que sí cuando me ofrecieron ir a
entrenar a altos ejecutivos en eeuu o
cuando dije que sí cuando me ofrecieron
liderar un equipo en el cual yo tenía
que obtener resultados e influenciar a
gente que se encontraba sentada en
singapur en india en europa en eeuu y
sudamérica el decir que sí a todas y
cada una de las oportunidades que se me
ha presentado en la vida donde muchas
veces he tenido miedo donde muchas veces
ni siquiera puedes ver el beneficio de
manera inmediata pero donde todas y cada
una de las veces ha estado el
crecimiento personal y eventualmente el
crecimiento profesional
el siguiente consejo que te quiero dar
también muy importante es el soporte y
conexiones vivimos en un mundo que
funciona a base de sociedades grupos
gente todos necesitamos en algún momento
alguien que esté cerca de nosotros así
que yo te recomiendo no te aísles ten
siempre a alguien tu papá' tu amigo tu
pareja quien tú quieras alguien en quien
confíes que pueda darte un consejo quien
pueda darte una opinión diferente y por
eso es muy importante
rodearte de gente inteligente gente que
te sume no que reste porque también es
cierto que te vas a encontrar con gente
que te querrá ver fallar
yo tengo la gran fortuna de estar casada
con un hombre muy inteligente un hombre
que tiene la independencia autonomía e
inteligencia para no dejar manejar su
vida es más estereotipos sociales el
cual ha estado cerca de mí para apoyarme
para darnos la mano para recordarme
incluso lo que yo puedo lograr y cuánto
valgo cuando más lo necesita do que
juntos hemos aprendido tomar las
decisiones en base a lo que es mejor
para nosotros como familia y no en base
lo que la sociedad espera cómo debemos
de comportarnos
pero recuerda no es suerte tú decides el
tipo de personas que te quieres rodear
y los últimos dos puntos que te quiero
recomendar consejos es la resiliencia si
algo te puedo asegurar es que siempre
habrá algún momento en que algo nos
saldrá como tú lo esperas en que tú
consideras que estabas preparado que
tenías todo para ganar y simplemente no
se dio aquí lo importante es que no te
quedes tirado que te levantes que no te
compadezcas que no juzgues que pienses
que la sociedad es injusta dios es
injusto la vida es injusta que te
levantes de limpieza en polvo mires
hacia atrás si hay algo que corregir
aprendas y entonces mires hacia adelante
elijas tu nuevo objetivo y comiences de
nuevo
y el último consejo que quisiera darte
pero el más importante es ser feliz
disfruta el camino porque si no nada de
lo que hemos hablado de todo ese trabajo
duro valentía perseverancia habrá valido
la pena
yo he tenido que estar en constante
viajes de trabajo los cuales me han
llevado a estar en más de 50 60 aviones
al año alejándome de mi familia me he
perdido por supuesto de cumpleaños
eventos escolares ceremonias reuniones
familiares muchos muchos fines de semana
con mi familia pero créanme estoy muy
feliz me encanta lo que hago disfruto lo
que hago porque también he conocido
cultura gente personalidades gente que
me ha enseñado que no importa si eres el
trabajador que está en celaya en la
fábrica o eres el ejecutivo que está en
el otro lado del mundo todos tenemos
sueños tenemos deseos tenemos miedos
que no importa si eres hombre o eres
mujer pero que si te esfuerzas cien
veces tus miedos te levantas y aprendes
trabajas duro pero sobre todo si
disfrutas lo que haces
los resultados se darán
y actualmente tengo la fortuna de
trabajar en una empresa para la cual la
inclusión y la diversidad es muy
importante tan importante que este año
se unió al movimiento paradigma de
paridad en el cual se comprometió que
para el año 2030 tendrá igualdad de
género en todas y cada una de sus
posiciones de liderazgo como ves el
cambio se está dando las empresas están
reconociendo todos los beneficios de
abrazar la paridad pero sin embargo el
principal cambio depende de ti y debe de
nacer dentro de ti por favor atrévete
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]